Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Choisir le métier de pâtissier,
c’est choisir de régaler les gens.
C’est créer des émotions positives,
apporter de la joie, du bonheur.
Choisir le métier de chef aujourd’hui,
c’est aussi se poser la question de savoir
comment je veux nourrir le monde :
avec quels ingrédients, quels produits ?
Comment je vais les préparer ?
Comment je vais les transformer ?
Et est-ce que cela va avoir
un impact positif ou négatif ?
J’ai choisi de me consacrer depuis
sept ans à la pâtisserie végétale.
On peut parler de pâtisserie végane,
de pâtisserie végétalienne -
peu importe, c’est la même chose.
J’ai choisi le terme de végétal
parce que le végétal, c’est beau.
Il faut que ce soit beau.
Faire de la pâtisserie sans utiliser
de produits d’origine animale,
c’est chambouler les codes,
c’est bousculer des siècles de tradition.
Aujourd’hui, la pâtisserie végétale
apporte vraiment son lot d’émotions
et répond vraiment à une demande
en termes de gourmandise.
Alors, quitte à tout chambouler, autant
le faire bien et allons jusqu’au bout.
Assurons-nous qu’elle soit gourmande déjà,
et faisons aussi en sorte
qu’elle soit plus saine.
Et si on peut,
faisons en sorte qu’elle ait l’impact
le plus positif possible sur le monde.
Quand j’ai commencé, à mes débuts
il y a environ sept ans,
je n’avais pas vraiment de méthode.
Faire des gâteaux sans utiliser d’œufs,
sans beurre, ce n’était pas simple.
J’avais tendance à prendre tous les
ingrédients qui me venaient sous la main :
de la farine, du sucre, de l’huile, des
fruits, de la compote, des légumes même.
Je mélangeais le tout, on faisait une
petite mixture et hop ! au four !
en croisant les doigts
ou en faisant une petite prière.
On attendait de voir le résultat.
Voilà la photo
de la toute première fournée.
Photo vintage réelle de la toute première
fournée de pâtisseries végétales.
Je pense que vous n’auriez pas aimé goûter
la première version du gâteau
végétal au chou-fleur.
C’est abominable. (Rit)
D’ailleurs, il n’y a jamais eu
d’autres versions.
Puis finalement soutenue et encouragée
par mon professeur de pâtisserie,
celui qui m'avait tout appris.
et à force de travail, j’ai fini
par trouver de meilleures recettes,
de bonnes recettes en pâtisserie végétale.
C’est aussi à ce moment-là
que j’ai commencé à enseigner avec lui.
Plus tard, j’ai créé ma propre école.
Je me souviens du premier
bon gâteau que j’ai créé.
C’était un gâteau assez simple
à base de farine, de yaourt végétal,
de biscuits écrasés que j’avais rajoutés
pour apporter du goût,
et j’avais cuit le tout à la vapeur.
Ça, c’était nouveau.
Eh bien, ce gâteau,
il était extrêmement moelleux.
Cette cuisson avait vraiment conféré
à la texture de ce gâteau
quelque chose d’exceptionnel.
Ce gâteau, il était tellement bon
que la première fois que je l’ai mangé,
j’en ai pleuré.
J’en ai pleuré d’émotion,
et aussi un peu de fierté.
Surtout après tous ces échecs.
Mon ex-mari à l’époque, il m’a
prise un peu pour une folle. (Rit)
(Chuchote) Oui.
(Rit)
Peu importe, passer pour
une folle ou une marginale,
ça m’importait peu,
j’avais vraiment des convictions.
Je n’ai rien lâché,
j’ai continué à travailler.
J’ai créé tout un répertoire
de préparations, de gâteaux, de crèmes,
que j’ai rebaptisés
puisque c’était des créations.
Il y a par exemple la crème Alba,
qui est une crème très
simple avec de la crème pâtissière -
un tiers de crème pâtissière, un tiers de
lait végétal et un tiers d’huile de coco.
Elle fond dans la bouche,
elle apporte une sensation de légèreté
et, en même temps,
elle est extrêmement gourmande.
Il y a également la mousse Fomico,
une mousse à base de fruits -
80% de fruits -
donc très très intense et qui ne contient
pas du tout de matière grasse.
Donc elle est légère comme un nuage.
Il y a également la crème Estérel,
qui est une crème fouettée,
comme une chantilly,
à base de lait de soja, de beurre
de cacao, et qui tient très bien.
On la travaille exactement
comme une chantilly.
Cette crème, la crème Estérel,
à l’époque, quand je la faisais,
j’y mettais un petit peu de sucre, un peu
de vanille pour lui donner du parfum,
et également un petit peu d’épaississant,
de la gomme xanthane.
C’est un produit qui est extrêmement
utilisé par les chefs.
Dans des restaurants haut de gamme,
pour rattraper des sauces qui ont tranché,
par des chefs pâtissiers
également dans les labos -
vous en trouverez partout -
mais aussi chez les industriels.
C’est du E415.
À cette époque, j’étais boostée
par l’envie de progresser.
Je me suis intéressée
à tous ces produits dits améliorants,
tous ces additifs alimentaires
qui sont souvent des texturants.
C'est très facile de se les procurer
quand on est professionnel.
Il suffit de demander le catalogue.
Je n’avais même pas besoin de le demander.
Étant dans la recherche,
on me les a envoyés d’office.
Et là, tout un monde, tout un univers
de petites poudres blanches magiques
qui s'offrait à moi.
Épaississants, gélifiants,
stabilisants, émulsifiants,
la liste est longue.
Aujourd’hui, on peut donner n’importe
quelle texture à n’importe quel aliment.
On peut aussi, si on veut,
lui donner le goût qu’on veut.
Et si on veut, on peut même
faire en sorte qu’il se conserve
très très très longtemps.
Voilà. Quelque chose vous gêne ?
La communauté scientifique
s’accorde à dire
qu’il n’y a pas de risques pour la santé,
surtout aux doses qui sont réglementées.
N’étant pas scientifique,
je ne remettrai pas ça en question.
En revanche, quand on joue
au petit chimiste comme ça,
on se croit toujours
plus malin que les autres.
En fait, on a l’impression d’avoir
une longueur d’avance sur les autres.
Mais ce qui me dérange le plus,
c’est que, plus on va utiliser
ces produits texturants, ces améliorants,
finalement,
moins on va retrouver l’émotion.
Un très bon exemple : l’année dernière,
on a organisé le premier
concours professionnel
de pâtisserie végétale, à Chambéry.
On a réuni plutôt un beau jury.
On a dégusté énormément
de très très belles pâtisseries,
toutes plus belles les unes que les
autres, de très belles réalisations.
Dans ce jury, il y avait
des chefs pâtissiers travaillant
dans des restaurants étoilés,
meilleurs ouvriers de France,
des palais vraiment aiguisés.
On s’est tous accordés pour dire
que les réalisations étaient vraiment
très belles, très techniques,
les découpes impeccables, les couleurs,
la structure, la construction,
parfaites pour Instagram.
En revanche, en termes d’émotion,
on est resté un petit peu sur notre faim.
J’entends encore mon collègue dire -
c’était son baptême
de pâtisserie végétale,
il n’en avait jamais vraiment goûté.
Il disait :
« C’est vraiment très intéressant. »
C’était gentiment dire,
« très intéressant ».
« Par contre, je ne sais pas
si j’aime ou si je n’aime pas. » (Rit)
En gros, pour l’émotion, on repassera.
Mais il ne faut pas être trop dur,
c’était le premier concours.
C’était déjà très bien
de l’avoir organisé.
Finalement, la personne
qui a remporté la compétition
avait misé plutôt sur des techniques,
des recettes simples,
des goûts francs, une belle exécution, pas
forcément une surenchère de techniques.
Et elle a gagné.
Ça a été une très belle victoire,
une belle récompense,
et une grande fierté pour Juliette,
mon élève.
Finalement,
il a fallu faire très compliqué
pour savoir apprécier les choses simples.
Il a fallu des années d’échanges
avec des chefs,
des enseignants, des boulangers, des
pâtissiers, des chercheurs, des ingénieurs
pour comprendre et avoir le déclic.
Dans la composition des ingrédients,
on a des tas d’actions
naturelles qui sont déjà là.
En les étudiant,
on peut quasiment tout faire.
Au final, qu’est-ce qui remplace
le mieux les œufs
dans une pâtisserie végétale ?
Je vais vous le dire.
C’est tout simplement les amidons
naturellement contenus
dans quasiment toutes les farines,
la maîtrise de l’émulsion,
savoir comment on va
intégrer une matière grasse,
comment on va la mélanger
pour la texture et la saveur.
Ça va être
de réaliser une belle cuisson pour
optimiser la réaction de Maillard,
cette réaction chimique qui permet
d’obtenir cette belle couleur dorée
et qui va apporter
beaucoup plus de saveur.
Rien qu’avec ces trois points clés,
on peut quasiment tout faire.
Alors pourquoi faire compliqué ?
Pourquoi créer des produits bourrés
d’additifs et de texturants
que personne ne peut reproduire chez soi ?
Pourquoi créer des produits
ultra transformés qui dénaturent
notre rapport à l’alimentation
et qui empêchent notre cerveau
d’identifier ce qu’il mange ?
Ce qu’on ne sait pas faire
de manière simple,
peut-être qu’il faut accepter
de ne pas le faire,
de ne pas chercher à tricher sans cesse.
Choisir d’enseigner,
choisir de produire ou de consommer
de la pâtisserie végétale,
c’est agir sur plusieurs points.
Déjà, on contribue à réduire
la souffrance animale
dont personne ne veut plus aujourd'hui.
C'est aussi agir pour l'environnement.
Eh oui, parce qu’on va réduire
la surface d’exploitation agricole,
on va limiter
l’utilisation des ressources,
on va réduire la pollution
et le rejet de CO2.
Et si en plus,
on est capable de retirer ou de remplacer
des ingrédients comme les œufs,
comme les produits laitiers,
on peut adapter cette méthode à tout.
On peut retirer également les additifs.
On peut aussi retirer les allergènes.
Aujourd'hui, il existe plus de 20
allergènes officiels dans la liste.
Et on peut même encore aller plus loin.
On peut adapter des recettes pour des
personnes souffrant de diabète.
On sait faire ça.
On peut agir à la fois sur la souffrance
animale, l’environnement et la santé.
La connaissance,
c’est un outil qui permet de progresser.
C’est la possibilité pour chaque chef
de faire des choix éclairés,
de nourrir le monde autrement,
et sans doute mieux.
On peut voir beaucoup d’initiatives
qui vont dans ce sens aujourd’hui.
À Rambouillet, par exemple,
un groupe de copains renonce
à 30 ans à de brillantes carrières
pour retourner dans leur coin,
se réunir et planter ensemble
des graines de soja
pour produire du tofu,
du lait végétal pour la collectivité.
Et pourquoi ? Parce que c’est
la protéine la plus durable qui soit.
À Pantin, j’ai accompagné des écoles,
une nouvelle école de cuisine
qui repense le métier de restaurateur.
On y parle zéro déchet,
produits locaux, de saison.
On y enseigne la pâtisserie végétale
mais également des techniques
géniales de fermentation,
des techniques ancestrales
que personne n’enseigne
et qui pourtant apportent
un goût génial à tous les aliments
et en plus sont excellentes pour la santé
parce qu’elles vont booster
l’immunité naturelle du corps.
Et ça, c’est génial !
À Bordeaux,
on a créé un comité pédagogique
constitué de chefs prestigieux,
des pâtissiers,
des spécialistes dans leur domaine,
que ce soit l’écologie, l’agriculture
ou les médias dans la gastronomie,
pour réellement réfléchir à la manière
d’enseigner la pâtisserie aujourd’hui.
La pâtisserie végétale
y a une place importante
et on répond vraiment à la question :
« Comment veut-on nourrir le monde ? »
Donc clairement, avec gourmandise,
mais aussi avec des valeurs.
On crée les nouveaux programmes,
les nouveaux contenus,
les nouveaux savoir-faire,
toutes ces nouvelles compétences
qui vont arriver dans l’alimentation.
On crée même des -
On commence à créer des nouveaux diplômes
et ça, c'est assez énorme.
C’est un énorme pas vers l’avant.
Six ans après avoir créé
les premières formations professionnelles
en pâtisserie végétale,
je suis très heureuse
d’assister à tout ça.
Il existe mille manières
d’atteindre un objectif,
même un objectif qui paraît
impossible au départ.
A chaque étape, on peut faire
un choix et en mesurer l’impact.
Honnêtement, aujourd'hui, on a tous les
ingrédients qu'il faut pour le faire bien.
Reste maintenant à savoir
quelle sera la meilleure recette.
(Applaudissements)